Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This piece of work is about reducing the time
needed to simulate elastic deformations by
means of precomputation.
Okay, so what does the term precomputation
mean?
If we are at an open book exam and we are
short on time, which is, basically, every
time, it would be much better to do a precomputation
step, namely studying at home for a few days
before, and then, when we are there, we are
endowed with quite a bit of knowledge, and
are guaranteed to do much better than trying
to grasp the simplest concepts on the spot.
This precomputation step we only have to do
once, and it almost doesn't matter how lengthy
it is, because after that, we can answer any
question in this topic in the future.
Well, sometimes passing exams is not as easy
as described here, but a fair bit of precomputation
often goes a long way.
Just saying.
The authors have identified 3 major bottlenecks
in already existing precomputation techniques,
and proposed optimizations to speed them up
considerably at the cost of higher memory
consumption.
For instance, the algorithm is trained on
a relatively large set of training pose examples.
If we don't have enough of these training
examples, the quality of the animations will
be unsatisfactory, but if we use too many,
that's too resource intensive.
We have to choose just the right amount, and
the right kinds of poses, which is a highly
non-trivial process.
Note that this training is not the same kind
of training we are used to see with neural
networks.
This work doesn't have anything to do with
neural networks at all!
The results of the new technique are clearly
very close to the results we would obtain
with standard methods, however, the computation
time is 20 to 2000 times less.
In the more favorable cases, computing deformations
that would take several hours can take less
than a second.
That is one jaw-dropping result and a hefty
value proposition indeed.
This example shows that after a short precomputation
step, we can start torturing this poor armadillo
and expect high-quality elastic deformations.
And there is a lot of other things to be learned
from the paper.
Gram-Schmidt orthogonalization, augmented
Krylov iterations, Newton-PCG solvers.
Essentially, if you pick up a dry textbook
on linear algebra, and for every technique
you see there, you ask what on Earth this
is useful for, you wouldn't have to go through
hundreds of works, you would find a ton of
answers in just this one absolutely amazing
paper.
Also, please don't forget that you Fellow
Scholars make Two Minute Papers happen.
If you wish to support the show and get access
to cool perks, like an exclusive early access
program where you can watch these episodes
16-24 hours in advance, check out our page
on Patreon.
Just click on the icon with the letter P at
the end of this video or just have a look
at the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!